sally i love you and i cannot wait to
continue what we have going
you're amazing i'm a lucky guy you stand
by me sally and johnny you two have had
a journey together you've emerged on the
other side
probably stronger than ever how are you
guys feeling incredible
literally on top of the world like what
just happened it's just wild
and i get to do this guys so i'm very
very happy
yeah i mean looking back on the whole
experience so much happened
you know we met so many people so many
people left so many people stayed and
you know meeting her was definitely the
best you know part of the experience
falling in love was so unexpected
it happened and i'm so you know
appreciative
you know the chance that i got you know
to have this experience with her you by
my side the whole entire time
it's beautiful johnny are you ready to
be woken up every morning stella you
seem like a big morning person
i'm a huge morning person look she she
can't look we're going to be we're going
to be doing distance for a little bit
since you can't you know bang pants and
deposit hands
to wake me up in the morning or give me
an elbow to the ribs anymore
definitely going to be missing that it's
not going to be happening anytime soon
what is the plan for you too you're
going to go do long distance you're
going back where
what's the next steps so i'm going to
sacramento he's going to virginia for a
while
but both moving to l.a very very soon so
we'll be
here each other soon as in like next
week yeah two weeks from now
like we're about to jump into this thing
we're about to hit the ground
running yeah this is exciting for both
of us just being able to be on the
outside with each other
moving to the same city i feel like it's
the best move for us just because we're
gonna be close we're gonna see each
other
while we were in the villa i was like
how long do you think it's gonna take
before we like see each other after this
and i was so worried about his answer
and he goes oh the weak i was like oh
what the hell okay yeah
i'm sorry i'm trying to see her oh
that's so good
so i i'd hate to bring up casa more
again but
i'm sure it's been relayed to you guys
at this point that that was a big big
topic for
for the viewers and you guys kind of got
some hints of the tweets from the real
world so
how hard was it to not let what you were
thinking america was thinking influence
your relationship at all
it was difficult especially because i
was already moved past it you know what
i mean i don't even like
want to even go there and so to have
that like resurface and to see what it
did to him like
that was very difficult for me and i
feel like it sucked but it was
definitely something that like made us
stronger and
we have mastered the art of picking
ourselves up and pushing forward and
i feel like it's prepared us for
absolutely anything i tried to separate
the fact that we were on a tv show and
just try to be my genuine self
i did everything you know knowing i was
going to be honest about it
coming back to sally i told her the
truth and i knew that
some way shape or form was going to be
brought up multiple times for us to
rehash it but me and her
you know we kind of handled it within
the first couple of days the way we
wanted to
yeah but having an outside you know
third party come in and continuously
bring it up and try and provoke us
and stir it up and to still come out on
the other side stronger
you know it's very it's very refreshing
and reassuring uh just
for what we can handle on the outside
because i know there's gonna be a lot of
things thrown at us
yeah but the reality of it is like that
situation
is in our past and we know that we're
gonna continue
continuously get things about it because
that is the only flaw
that anyone can point out in our
relationship and i don't even see it as
necessarily a flaw
i think it was just something that
happens in the outside world and it made
us stronger
we can literally take on anything now so
i'm like come for us
america try harder that part that was
shown
our relationship was like two or three
percent of what happened
in the villa we had 97 at least for me
of just greatness every single day in
there we were not talking about casa and
war
was amazing waking up to going to sleep
with each other all the little jokes we
have
all the little games we play it's just
incredible
the time that we had together so if that
is the focal point of our relationship
it's kind of sad
because you know i know people love
drama people love you know heartbreak
and stuff like that but
if that was the focal point and they
didn't get to see the real us then
that's just a shame
yeah and it really sucks too like
because
i would not back someone so much if i
wasn't
like if they weren't deserving of it you
know what i mean like johnny really is
such a stand-up guy like he is perfect
and it's just like for that to like
have people question his character like
really really
sucked you know what i mean because i'm
like he's this amazing guy and
i don't want him to be viewed as costa
more like we are not costs anymore we
are so much more than that
i would not be so ride or die for
someone if they weren't deserving of it
like he's amazing so sally your
friendship with justine
was one of my favorite connections to
watch team celine
what did it mean to you to have this
support system with each other
throughout your time on love island she
is my soul sister
like love island would not have been
what it was if i did not have her like
yes i love you boy but like
just be like literally adore that girl
so
much and if if people could have voted
for celine to win we would have won the
whole thing like i'm
let me be real justine
i don't know i'm sorry no one stood a
chance at that point i don't i don't see
you i feel like me and kayla that was
strong
hell no if selena
but honestly though like it wouldn't
have been what it was without her
she saved me she was my saving grace
like throughout the entire time like
just getting the laugh with her cry with
her all the advice that she's given me
like she's my homegirl and i just can't
wait to force her to move in with me
outside of this
every time justine's not around the mood
changes and it makes me feel like
chop liver or something because i'm like
i'm not good enough for like the next
hour or two while she's gone
like come on now i'm not myself when she
got around i'm like that
is there anything that you would change
about your experience on love island
not at all like even though we didn't
have it the easiest like
i would not change a single thing i feel
like everything happened the way that it
needed to
and it only brought us stronger and
closer together
and it was just honestly like the most
amazing love story
i have ever had like one really
important conversation that we had was
he was telling me that he was going to
show me that like
fairy tale love stories exist and i was
like yeah whatever but like
he did he gave that to me you know what
i mean like i would not change a single
thing it was
the most amazing experience of my entire
life the big focal point of our
relationship
being costa more although it did help us
grow
although we are stronger for it today i
would go back and i would not even
show that girl the time of day because
the dress and you know the sleep that i
lost over
all of that drama oh like surrounding
costa more
i would it was not worth it you know to
have to go through all that and put her
through all that
you know those couple pisses and cuddle
all that just
not worth the at all you know we
we gained a lot from it but i always
favor myself the time and i'll save her
the heartache you know and go back and
just not do that
well said are you both planning on
watching the show back do you think
you'll watch it back
it's gonna take a while like i feel like
i'm just gonna cringe so hard on myself
but
i think eventually i'll get there i
wanna hit like the highlights like our
date like watching us see the handshake
the nail painting like
all the really really good moments i
think i'm gonna want to watch right away
but everything else i'm like i don't
know if i can watch that yeah
i'm like i'm kind of same way like i
want to watch the big moments i want to
watch the challenges
i want to watch the dates but you know i
know
that at one point i started being
portrayed as negative but
every single day in the villa i was a
positive guy
you know i was always trying to joke i
was always you know trying to be funny
or whatever it is and to think that you
know i might not be portrayed that way
because of all this negative energy
surrounding castle more
kind of that's kind of sucky for me so i
don't know if i want to watch all the
way through immediately but
of course
people that are close to me the people
that were actually there didn't know the
truth and
that's all that really matters you know
it just kind of sucks there's that
negative connotation behind us because
there's nothing negative
you